for our next big release of OS 10 we  knew we wanted to build on those  strengths of Yosemite with some really  great refinements and advances the only  really real question of course was what  to call it so the new name for OS 10 is  OS 10 El Capitan so we saw in El Capitan  a powerful form of search and spotlight  that lets you compose your searches in  your own words it knows more than ever  can look up whether stocks game scores  we saw gestures for instance just  swiping to delete in mail and of course  pin sites in Safari and the ability to  easily mute tabs a great new notes app  that supports text Eiling checklists and  graphical links and better window  management than ever with a beautiful  new mission control interface easy  access to your spaces bar and of course  the ability to do split view and adjust  it to see exactly what you're looking  for every pixel of your display devoted  to your content